uh we got the story from the hill
because this is part of the defense and
i think we should bring it up
chauvin defense attorney claims floyd
said quote i ate
too many drugs in a rest video this is
really weird
because you can't really hear exactly
what they're saying in this video it's
just this loud clamoring
i guess maybe george floyd said it but
to me it's like that
that yanny laurel thing if if someone
plays a weird sound and tells you
here's what they said you'll hear it you
know there's this really funny
song where they have it's like it's like
it's a very short
meme song i remember what it was it's
like 30 seconds where they're saying the
same thing over and over again
the same phrase but the text shows a
different phrase yes
so it sounds like they're saying
different things but it's the same word
over and over and over again
so when they play this video and you
can't really make it out and they're
like doesn't it sound like floyd said i
ate too many drugs you're like
maybe maybe so here's but here's where
it gets crazy
the prosecutor says he didn't say i ate
too many drugs he said i ain't do any
drugs
which one was it well hold on he said
one of the two right that's the argument
so either he said he's admitting to it
or he's lying because we know the talks
report that he did eat the drugs
so what what do you think he said well i
i don't know what he says and it's not
going to matter if shoving didn't write
it in a case report
because shelby can just deny that he
heard anything but the thing is is that
if
the the prosecution is shooting
themselves in the foot again
if he said i ate too many drugs and
chauvin
did not recognize that he needed to be
he needed
um aid to be rendered to him then
chauvin would
would be potentially culpable in not
rendering aid to a person who admitted
to swallowing drugs
this is and the prosecution turned
around and said no he didn't say that he
said i didn't do no drugs well then that
makes chauvin even more
you know a reasonable person because
he's saying i didn't do no drugs so
there's no reason to put him on the side
in the recovery position that's
that's what i wanted to get to with this
story is that it seems like the defense
is pulling a bug's bunny
on the prosecutors so you guys you know
in looney tunes when
daffy and bugs and this says rabbit
season and duck season and
and daffy say it's rabbit season and
bugs like no it's duck season then all
of a sudden bugs goes
it's rabbit season and then daffy goes
no it isn't it's duck season
and then bugs goes okay and then elmer
fudd shoots daffy
that's basically what happened they're
like didn't he say he ate drugs no no he
didn't say that he said he didn't eat
drugs
oh okay so chauvin should not have
rendered aid because they didn't do any
drugs
i'm wondering are they that brilliant or
it's just falling that way slipping on
banana peels and doing back
because what they're trying to argue is
see it's two things being argued here
they're trying to preserve the the
prosecution is trying to preserve the
character of george floyd
so him saying i ate too many drugs is
proving that his character is a drug
user and then he's crazy out of his mind
but they're fighting that they're saying
no he said i didn't do no drugs george
floyd wasn't a bad guy
but that's playing into the lap of the
defense because they're not
caring if he's a good guy or a bad guy
they're trying to decide whether chauvin
was rightfully
knowledgeable about him being overdosing
potentially overdosing from drugs should
he been
set in a recovery position was he
experiencing excited delirium
which is which is another term that i
haven't at least i haven't heard every
word of the case but i haven't heard
excited delirium brought up much
i wonder if like the prosecutor or the
defense is going to listen to this
and they're going to get the idea
because the trial is ongoing and then
the state process this prosecutor is
going to be like the other day we
we mentioned that you know the defense
said
george floyd's had ate too many drugs
yes you know we agree he did say that
chauvin should have rendered aid because
the defense agrees that's what he said
right
yeah that's that's crazy how that works
out that way that's true they're trying
to defend the character they're shooting
themselves in the foot it's too late now
i know you have the audio can you play
that audio is it available
i can't no not on youtube because it's
part of the whole youtube doesn't allow
you to show the floyd incident
i don't know how you guys feel but once
i found out that he had fentanyl nor
fentanyl
and that was overdosing and meth that i
just it looks like a drug overdose death
well i don't know well just just for
just for the sake of understanding
fentanyl for a second
fentanyl is one of the most potent and
dangerous drugs you that i know that
exists at this point
it is more you know dangerous than a
horse tranquilizer
it is more potent in little little bitty
grams of it
um if you research and i did a video
about this and it showed a phoenix
police officer and i'll tell you how it
evolved
a phoenix police officer with gloves on
was handling
a drug laced with fentanyl and he passed
out and they had to administer narcan to
him or he would have died
just for handling inhaling vapor
from a drug laced with fentanyl wow and
our our um department when i when i was
on the department fentanyl when they
first came to
re you know to our understanding how
potent it was
every drug we test you have to wear a
full hazmat suit
to test every drugs gloves you got to
wear a mask
and you got to have a complete hazmat
suit on because fentanyl can seep
through the skin
you can inhale it and if you ingest it
you might as well call yourself dead so
we pulled up from the dea.gov an image
of a lethal
dose of fentanyl and it's next to a
penny
have you ever seen this photo no i have
it it it's
it's 1 100th the size of a penny yeah a
lethal dose of fentanyl
it's it shows a penny on the screen and
there's tiny little white specks
yeah we've i've heard these stories man
i remember in chicago they called it
super heroine
because like like you said you could
accidentally just inhale a tiny bit
you're dead people didn't get it so it's
like lab created opiate that didn't
exist
12 years ago like they just it's a new
thing right i don't know when it is
yeah i think that they're i don't know
if it's new or they're newly
administering this as a as a additive to
these drugs
because think about it see how little
that is you
you get a lot of that it go a long way
you sprinkle a little that
in some methamphetamine which is
probably what floyd was
taking and it'll drive you nuts and you
only need a little bit and you could
charge way more
because you got you got some powerful
stuff you know what kind of meth it was
that was in his system
just mathematically well there's like
methylenedioxy methamphetamine
mdma a crystal meth which is much more
dangerous than mdma
in in the tax report it's just listed it
says methamphetamine and i almost think
that any methamphetamine
that is street level is going to be the
crystal methamphetamine because it's the
way they they
cook it and that's my assumption and
they begin to sell it that way and
people get in these little crystals i've
never seen
methamphetamine um in any other form
except crystal
um and then if they mix uh uh
fentanyl with with crystal meth is that
the idea that's what the speed ball is
speed ball yeah
yeah and normally you know speed ball
can be mixed with methamphetamine heroin
um so it's it's kind of like that
mixture of a of an upper and uh so some
sort of down yeah
with some some opiate with the upper you
know and
typically it's methamphetamine and dude
that's dangerous man people do speed
balls
that's a that's a thing people do speed
balls all the time and
they don't they don't live with all of
that you know what i'm saying
you're taking an injustice to your body
over time you're going to die
heroin is killed you know i had a family
member die from a heroin overdose
heroin is pretty legitimate you know
these opiates are really really
legitimate
and floyd i guarantee you that
methamphetamine
and fentanyl probably isn't his typical
drug
i think that he probably started using
that after a while
i'm pretty sure you use all kinds of
stuff um
they'll do anything to get high you know
if you if you're a crystal meth
you you have done a lot of other stuff
to get a high
and crystal meth is kind of like
especially if you're black
and and i'm not making it in the race
thing it's like it's a cultural thing
in most black areas they do crack
they crack rocks they do crack when you
start getting a meth
you are on another level you have now
branched out of the typical drug arena
that you're in and you're starting to go
and deal with people who are on another
level of drug of drug production
um and that's just my opinion that's not
every city but
in my city that was do you know the
lethal do you know a lethal dose of
methamphetamine is
no i i tried to look this up it's really
hard to find fentanyl was was
was easy to look up not only does the
dea have a photo showing you how just a
tiny bit of fentanyl can kill you
but they also talk about between 10 and
20 nanograms per milliliter is
anesthesia range where you basically get
knocked out
and that at seven nanograms per
milliliter in combination with other
drugs
is where you're in overdose territory
right otherwise it's around like 11 or
so
now the north fentanyl in the system is
a metabolite of fentanyl meaning he
might have even had 17 nanograms per
milliliter when he first ingested this
he had 19 nanograms per milliliter of
methamphetamine in the system
i don't know what the lethal
concentration for methods i couldn't
find it
but he had a lot he also had tobacco
which is a stimulant caffeine yeah
oh caffeine and thc cottoning or
something yeah that's right yeah yeah
yeah two different kinds of thc in a
system
he had a big combination like i'm saying
this guy is a drug a habitual drug user
he's going to his next high you know and
this was his next high
and then you know but but i don't think
he was in he wasn't
i don't think he was actively getting
high at the time is that he got caught
with a whole thing
of drugs and he had to swallow it and
and he killed him i mean
what's the guy the little rapper that
was on the airplane yeah i remember he
flew on a private jet and he had drugs
and he
well prince he died from fentanyl but
that's probably not what you're talking
about no it's a rapper it was recent a
rapper he landed somewhere
he's like 25. and uh they thought the
cops killed him or something like that
but what happened was he got caught with
marijuana
but he has other drugs that he ingested
and so he end up
ingesting them and dying like i said i
know people and i'm not going to
disclose
how i know them uh who they are
specifically but i know people that
have gotten caught by the cops that
juice juice i think it was juice world
was it juice world something yeah
percocet chicago airport yeah swallow
percocet
okay because he didn't want he didn't
want to get caught so he swallowed
more than you would take you're trying
to swallow the whole thing so you don't
get caught with any of it
because once it's in your body they
can't charge you anything that's a war
on drugs thing for me though you know
what i mean
it kind of man it's a whole ring of
behaviors but if people were just
growing methamphetamine you know what
you don't grow i mean it's a lot of
chemical compounds to get meth but
if you had cocaine and you were just
doing coca leaves and cocaine i don't
even know how it's made but
you just doing in your backyard who
cares nobody ever knows
this dude on a plane but no but how did
he get it
is the question what is he doing with it
it's another question
and a lot of times these people are
getting it through nefarious means
meaning that they are contributing to
the the cartel in mexico
and and all the trafficking that goes on
and gun gun smuggling and trade and
all of that goes in those drugs getting
here and then when they get here what
are they doing to other people
the distributor is killing people yeah
that's that's to me
if you sell drugs you sell if you sell
heroin to somebody
or you sell methamphetamine to somebody
i i would like for that to be a form of
attempted murder
if that person dies and you sold it to
him you should be charged with murder
but let's say we
we stop these laws also in the cartels
go out of business they're not gonna go
out of business
well you know what's going on in the
cartels now you wanna know they started
selling
with marijuana being legalized in a
bunch of different states they found a
new
cash crop that they've started seizing
upon
avocados no joke i saw an article
avocados
yeah so i would even went down to mexico
what are they doing with our avocados
just the avocados that you eat are they
doing something did you eat
businesses because they found they're
extremely valuable
and americans has a high demand for
avocados so with the legalization of
marijuana here's what ends up happening
is they're like
we used to have essentially a monopoly
on this product
because the government said it was
illegal so you needed someone under
under the radar to come and take it
well if it's legal we're going to
maximize profits
guess what now that people can get
cheaper illegal stuff avocados are worth
way more
so they started saying okay then they go
to these avocado farms and they're like
we're going to distribute this for you
from now on
and so what happens is a lot of that
starts a lot of the criminal enterprise
gets
it breaks down because the cartels are
like avocados are legal we just bring
them in you know thanks for checking out
this clip from the tim cast irl podcast
if you want to see the full show come
back to this channel youtube.com
tim cast irl monday through friday at
8pm where you can leave comments
and super chat and we actually will read
your comments
on the show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members
only content segments you can't get
anywhere else go to timcast.com become a
member
and we even have full bonus episodes
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time
you